معلومات امريكيه مسربه حدث نادر لكنه في
كل مره يسبب الكثير من الاوجاع لاول مره
منذ سنه 2013
عشرات الوثائق بعضها يحمل وسما سريا
للغايه نشرت عبر الانترنت ورغم انها
مجهوله المصدر الا انها زرعت الشكوك بين
الحلفاء وغيرت خططا عسكريه كلفت الكثير
البدايه كانت في يناير الماضي وفي مكان
غير متوقع موقع ديسكورد للدردشه منصه
تستهوي هو العاب الفيديو دون غيرهم تنشر
وثائق جماعتها اعين امريكا التي لا تنام
المعلومات بقيت حبيسه غرفه دردشه واحده
قبل ان ينشرها الاسبوع الماضي احد الاعضاء
في مجموعه اخرى اكثر عددا وهنا تحولت
الوثائق الى فضيحه الصحف الامريكيه
استلهمت هذه المره كل مادتها الاعلاميه من
موقع الدردشه دون مصدر اخر
البانتاجون اكد صحه اذ لم ينفيها وهو الذي
سبق الزمن على جبهتين محاوله يائسه لحذف
الوثائق ومطارده الخونه في اروقه المكان
الاكثر سريه في العالم
وهنا فتح الباب امام الاحتمالات امريكا
تشارك معلوماتها الاستخباراتيه مع دول
محدوده منها كندا وبريطانيا وقد تكون هذه
الدول مصدر التسريب ولا مسؤوليه لواشنطن
في ذلك لكن الفرضيه لا تقدم اجابه بخصوص
وثائق لا يجب ان تغادر مبنى البينتاجون
احتمال ثاني عسكري رفيع يعمل لصالح موسكو
التي نشرت الوثائق بعد استغلالها والدليل
انها عادت لاستخدام الطيرانها بكثافه
تزامنا مع انباء انهيار الدفاع الجوي
الاوكراني
فرضيه اخرى طرحت نفسها بقوه الوثائق
ركزت على اوكرانيا واثبتت ما كان يعتبر
دعايه الكرملين امريكا تشارك وتخطط وتدعم
الحرب اركان حرب الوكاله لها من يرفضها
وفي اعلى المستويات لكن بعض الاصوات في
روسيا بدات تحذر من خدعه امريكيه تهدف
لمناوره استخباراتيه قد تكون الاكبر في
القرن الحالي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات